生损失费可能比较难，
第一他不是强你，
第二他不是欺骗你，
他不是说他已婚欺骗你，
怀孕这个事儿有什么非自愿吗？
什么叫非自愿怀孕啊，
现在是非要到结婚的时候了，
但是因为彩礼的事情，
男方现在是太想管的这种态度，
然后我就是说已经没孕了，
想怎么起诉他来着，
你想起诉他什么，
他们现在就是既不结婚也不管你，
就这种态度等着我去找他，
然后我就说要不就算了吧，
孩子的话，
我自己一个人的，
我也不敢生，
怀孕几个月，
三个多月了，
你现在不应该是想起诉这个事儿，
你现在要及时止损。
还有一个原因，
当时怀孕我是不知道的，
她给我吃了那个就一怀孕的那个药吧，
她说那个药就是补身体的吧，
人家是因为我怀孕了，
所以就说彩礼也不想给，
就说你结婚的话，
你就直接跟我结婚，
然后也不管彩礼，
也没有其他的，
你要是不结婚的话，
你就直己看着办，
他爸妈就是给他去，
他也别管了，
就等着他要我来跟你讲一下，
你现在这个阶段才三个月，
你一定要及时的看清楚你未来的路，
你未来的路是什么呢？
你就算起诉了也没有用，
假设他要是不爱你，
他不想管你的话，
你起诉了可能一个月就是800的抚养费，
一天的抚养费也不够你养孩子的，
因为你养孩子这个过程当中，
你又不能挣钱，
他一个月给800，
给1000的抚养费，
屁都顶不上，
你饭都吃不上，
孩子奶粉都喝不上，
尿不湿都买不起，
就算你今天起诉他，
你胜利了，
你一个月拿。
1000块钱你没有意义，
不要去起诉他，
这个孩子肯定是不能要，
我那意次我怎么找他？
不要找，
不要说你甚至都应该骗他，
你说我骗你了，
我没怀孕，
我就想试一下你的真心，
就是他不知道，
就是检查过他都知道，
他陪你一起去检查的吗？
对对，
如果像这家人趁着女朋友怀孕了，
这家人就装死，
这家人就有什么好咬一窝都是一窝坏老鼠，
你跟他们家人有什么好打交道的，
你又要让他们家人跟你有过深的交集，
我再说一遍啊，
我为我自己说的话负责任，
我今天把话撂这儿了，
未来婆家，
包括公公，
包括婆婆，
包括未来的老公，
发现女方怀孕了，
这家人装死，
不出钱，
不出力，
不关心，
就是等着这个怀孕的女方来找他们家妥协的话，
这一家人就没有一个好鸟，
你嫁过去是不会有好日子过的，
所以你需要做的就是手术费2000，
那我自己哪怕没有钱，
我贷款，
我支付宝贷款，
我唯一贷贷款，
我贷款2000块钱，
我要把我自己的事情解决掉，
没有必要说为了让他们家给赔偿，
我还打一个官司，
让周围人都知道我怀过他们家的孩子，
完全没有必要，
我到时候不说是我要的，
我就说啊，
精子质量不好，
生化了没有翻倍，
没有胎心，
精子质量太差了，
自然就流掉了，
要我的话，
我就这么说，
我觉得我再没有必要找他了，
没有必要你相信我，
我给你选的这个方案就是对我们女孩。
最好的方案，
没有之一，
我现在我家人都知道，
之后就是我家人的意思就是要找她，
不要你这个故事里面的男方，
包括未来公公，
未来婆婆，
没有一个好鸟的话好，
那你们家就没有一个明白人，
你爸妈都不是什么明白人，
你一定要听我的，
这件事情我的意思是我就啥也不怪，
我自己把这个事情处理了，
但是家人知道的话，
我自己处理不了，
就是他们一定是要找进来的，
你们家人会绑着你吗？
会把你反锁在门里吗？
差不多，
那你们家人神经病，
你爸妈不光是脑子不清醒，
而且你爸妈有点病，
他们是不会让我生日的，
孩子就是也要那个男的负他该负的责任来，
听好了，
姑娘，
今天你能拿到自己的身份证，
拿到自己的手机，
自己有钱，
拿着自己的钱，
这个我是可以，
我看到有评论说就是想要钱啥的，
我爸的意思是我一分他的钱不要，
我就是让他付出代价，
这个意思，
他付出不了什么代价，
第一你俩不是强迫，
不是强迫他没有办法，
第二，
怀孕这个事儿你俩都有责任，
你情我愿的，
你为啥不让她带病，
你俩都有责任，
怀孕这事儿你俩都有责任，
嗯，
你让她付出什么代价吗？
手术费2000好，
他付1000，
有这个必要吗？
对对对，
我是觉得没这个必要，
我也不想就这么随便闲着，
他想要钱也可以这么说吧，
我之前咨询过一个律师，
他说是非要去打仗的话，
就各种赔，
属于费用吧，
都他承担。
然后我就是说那个非自愿怀孕的话，
这一条能不能争取。
有一个什律咨询损施费呀啥的，
我咨询过一个律师，
他说可以，
你问想问清楚了，
这要不要找律师，
精神损失费可能比较难，
第一他不是告你，
第二他不是欺骗你，
他不是说他已婚欺骗你。
怀孕这个事儿有什么非自愿吗？
什么叫非自愿怀孕很难，
反正你花了300块钱来问我，
我出的主意对得起这300块钱，
至于你听和不听，
这是你的人生课题啊，
就我自己把这个事情解决了，
然后就不要感染何人参与是吧？
反正第一我的判断就是你的未来公公婆婆和男方这家人没有一个好鸟，
你嫁过去没有好日子过。
第二，
就算打官司的话，
人家也付出不了什么代价，
你的代价更大。
第三，
你家里人也没有一个明白人，
没有一个脑子清醒的。
第4，
人生要紧处就这么几步，
就看你怎么决策了啊，
我知道这个结果自己是这，
但是你家里边所有人就不想让我一个人把事情都解，
很多事情你要明白，
没有人给你的生命兜底的，
你家里人也不能给你的生命兜底的，
你是那个最终要承担最后不利后果的人，
所以你要决断，
你也可以跟家里人说自然留掉的嘛，
这个我肯定憋不下去，
我也骗不了他们。
好，
我就说到这里了啊，
对，
还有一个问题就是吧，
我爸肯定是说他要去起诉，
但是起诉的话，
他嘴上说是我会负责到底，
真的走到那一步，
你人都找不到他的那种，
打官司真的挺难的，
姑娘，
你都很难证明这孩子是他的，
而且在吗？
当然你。
很难证明啊，
难点就在这儿，
怀孕之后不能证明是他的吗？
我就问你，
你怎么证明孩子是他的？
这个孩子你是不打算生出来的，
对不对？
那你怎么证明孩子是他的了？
我明白了，
你自己琢磨一下好，
谢谢姐啊，
嗯，
拜拜，
我知道我说这个话大家会觉得心理上有点一下子咯噔一下，
有点排斥，
但是确实是啊，
你想想，
本来你不想把这个孩子生下来，
你想要证明这个孩子是他的，
那你遭不遭罪吧？
你是不是还得花钱去做DNA，
你遭不遭罪吧？
关键是你就算花钱做了DNA，
就算证明了这个孩子是他的，
那你能得到什么呢？
给你三千五千的赔偿金有什么意思呢？
你要是能听进去劝的话，
你或许有重生的机会，
如果你听不进去劝的话，
可能没准儿到你7个月8个月的时候还来问我，
没准儿到时候孩子生完了时候还得来花钱来问我，
一步错就得步步错，
就一连串都得错，
记得点赞关注哦。